Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Matt Desmond, who's a professor of sociology
at Princeton University and also author of
the book Poverty by America.
Really appreciate your time today.
Looking forward to this conversation.
Speaker 6: Me, too.
Thanks for having me.
Speaker 1: So when we talk about poverty in
the United States, we know that on average,
and we can define average a few different
ways.
The United States is a very, very rich country.
We've all heard, you know, you put Bill Gates
in a room with poor people.
The mean net worth gets very high, but it
doesn't really represent the situation for
everybody other than Bill Gates in that room.
Is it a mathematical reality that even though
there are very rich people in the United States
and that sort of skews these averages, poverty
is still very high.
Do we need to go beyond that to really understand
the source of it?
Speaker 6: The United States stands alone,
is the richest country in the world with the
worst poverty.
So our child poverty rate is double that of
other poor nations like Canada, South Korea,
Germany.
Angus Deaton, The Economist, estimated that
over 5 million Americans live in abject poverty.
By global standards, getting by on $4 a day
or less.
And look, one in three of us live in homes
making $55,000 or less.
A lot of those homes aren't considered officially
poor.
But what else do you call trying to raise
two kids on 55 K in Boston?
So there's a giant amount of insecurity and
poverty in this rich land.
Speaker 1: When we think about poverty, part
of what we have to talk about is how we're
measuring it.
And as you're talking about, there are people
who, by the definition in the United States,
aren't poor, but that the practical day to
day realities certainly mirror poverty as
we understand it.
Can you talk a little bit about how the definition
of poverty in the United States has changed
over time?
Speaker 6: So there's a lot of different ways
to measure poverty.
Researchers do not agree on what the best
measure is.
You know, for me, one way to measure hardship
is just to measure hardship.
And so you can look at something like evictions.
They're up 20% since 2000.
Look at the share of families visiting food
pantries, up 19% since 2000.
The number of our homeless school kids is
up 74% since the Great Recession.
There's a lot of incredibly troubling signs
that poverty is not only persistent in America,
but growing.
You know, the poverty line is a is a pretty
flawed measure, but it also tracks pretty
well with those hardship measures.
The government introduced another measure
called the Supplemental Poverty Rate, the
Supplemental Poverty Measure in 2011, and
it counted for a lot of kind of government
programs the official poverty measure ignores.
But it also counted for like housing costs
and regional variation and cost of living,
which the official poverty measure also ignores.
And when they released that line, that new
poverty line, the country officially gained
3 million more poor people, actually, because
any reductions in poverty, offset by counting
aid, were more than kind of canceled out by
counting rising housing and medical costs.
Speaker 1: I want to really delve into one
of the aspects you write about in the book
that goes above and beyond defining some of
these terms, establishing what the situation
currently is and what it has been.
And you talk about how affluent Americans
knowingly or unknowingly contribute to poor
people remaining poor.
And this may be a difficult thing for for
some people to hear and to understand.
Can you talk a little bit about that and how
you lay out the case for the knowing or the
unknowing aspect of that?
Speaker 6: I ran across this line by the novelist
Tommy Orange, and it goes like this These
kids are jumping out of the windows, of burning
buildings, falling to their deaths.
And we think that the problem is that they're
jumping.
And when I read that sentence, I was like,
man, that sounds like the American poverty
that they know for for hundreds of years,
really.
Our focus has been on the poor and the poor
themselves, the jumpers.
You know, we should have been focusing on
the fire.
Who lit it?
Who's warming their hands by it?
And many of us, when we have that kind of
conversation and we want to talk about the
guy that's just a little richer than us or
a lot richer than us.
But the book is really trying to get a lot
of us.
And by us, I mean those of us that have found
some security and privilege in this country
to really yet look in hard in our lives and
realize how we're connected to the problem
and the solution.
A lot of us consume the cheap goods.
The working poor produce.
A lot of us are invested in the stock market.
Don't we benefit when our savings go up, even
if that savings comes at a human sacrifice?
Many of us benefit from tax breaks and we
don't think of those as welfare programs.
But they are.
They cost the government money and they put
money in our pocket.
And, you know, a lot of us hold on to those
tax breaks which starve anti-poverty spending.
And then we have the audacity to ask how can
we afford to do more as a country?
So I think that when you start looking at
the poverty problem by looking at the fire,
you kind of realize there's so much poverty
in America, not in spite of our wealth, but
because of it.
And I think that opens up new possibilities
for change.
Speaker 1: I'm interested in your thoughts
about to what degree there is moral, moral
responsibility at the individual decision
level.
Maybe this is analogous to you know, I've
talked with my audience before about how if
you think taxes should be higher, sending
the IRS more money isn't really policy.
It's not a solution to the problem.
It's not how we got here.
And so you can simultaneously pay, I think,
pay what you legally owe while advocating
that large swaths of people, maybe including
yourself, should be paying more.
If we apply that to the conversation that
we're having about poverty, how should the
individual look at their level of responsibility
here?
Speaker 6: I think we should commit ourselves
becoming poverty abolitionists.
You know, we should view poverty not as an
unfortunate aspect of American life, but as
an abomination.
And I think like other abolitionist movements,
the movement to abolish slavery, the prison,
you know, we should recognize that profiting
from someone else's pain corrupts all of us.
And so that's a that's a political project
that's going to take renewed political movements
and policies.
But it also is a personal project.
And that requires us to shop differently,
invest differently, thinking about taxes,
you know, for those of us that benefit from
this lopsided welfare state, the fact that
the country does so much more to guard fortunes
than to fight poverty.
Maybe we start a letter writing campaign.
We write our congressperson saying like, let's
wind down these things.
I don't need this.
This is also a neighbor to neighbor conversation
over the fence line conversation, not because,
you know, these little kind of personal moves
will abolish poverty, but those personal moves
multiplied over and over again built a political
will that empowers our lawmakers to act.
Speaker 1: One of the areas that's a topic
of much, much discussion with lawmakers and
in communities and with neighbors is about
zoning practices, approval boards for condos,
restricted income condos, all all these different
things.
Can we talk a little bit about that in the
sense of, you know, we know about the long
history of exclusionary zoning practices,
practices in lending.
Many of us have talked about those realities
we now sometimes see.
I mean, recently in Brooklyn, I was talking
with some friends about a project that was
putting in, I think it was a dozen or so units.
And the idea is we're going to sell the dozen
units to six buyers and these are going to
be income limited.
So everybody buys two units.
You live in one, we create lower income landlords.
It all sounds interesting, but is it really
going to are we really going to deal with
this problem piecemeal in that way?
Or does the solution really have to come from
higher and be broader and bigger?
Speaker 6: Yeah, I think both and everything,
all of the above, you know, and I think that
segregation continues to be a driving force
of poverty in America.
There's probably no more soulless phrase in
the English language than municipal zoning
ordinance, you know?
But like, that's a really good way to look
at the soul of a community.
You know, and 75% of our land, you can only
build a single, detached family home.
You know, we build these walls around our
community and we hoard affluence behind those
walls.
And that not only concentrates wealth, but
it concentrates poverty outside of our walls.
So we have to tear down the walls.
We have to start reaching for broader inclusive
communities, which really means, you know,
going down to your zoning board meeting at
Tuesday night and standing up and saying,
Look, I refuse to turn.
My kids opportunities.
My kids get living in this place.
We got to build this thing.
I refuse to be a segregationist.
So again, here's a conversation that sounds
very like policy and abstract.
Yeah, but it's also very personal.
You know, it's about how we vote, how we move.
The conversations we're having with our workers
at the WaterCooler, you know, in studies show
that, you know, Democrats are more likely
to embrace affordable housing in the abstract,
but are no more likely than conservatives
to vote yes in their own backyards.
You know, studies show that conservative renters
are actually more likely to vote yes on an
affordable housing project than liberal homeowners.
So I think our values cannot stop where our
property line begins.
We really have to live out these values in
our own lives.
Speaker 1: How do those values apply or connect
to?
Just to pick something that's often discussed
to get your take on it.
Something like mobile phones and in particular
in the context of activism.
Most of us have heard that and are aware that
mobile phones are connected to so-called conflict
minerals, typically from other countries.
We're now talking outside the U.S., even though
companies like Apple and others will say,
no, everything's fine.
We're ensuring this, that the other thing
isn't going on.
Videos have surfaced where we see that there
are very young looking, young looking people.
Hard to say.
They aren't kids digging by hand, etc.
Then they're manufactured.
They're sold in places like, you know, a T-Mobile
store, Apple store in the United States.
And we can look at the wages that are paid
there.
And they're not astronomically high, but they're
sort of like, okay, and a lot of these are
creating local jobs, etc., in the United States.
How do we take that panorama total and combine
it with the fact that many people who want
to be activists for exactly the issues you're
talking about use the devices to to that end.
Right.
So it also plays a role in their activism.
How do we unwind something so seemingly, seemingly
complicated when we apply the sort of standard
and critique you're applying?
Speaker 6: Yeah, I would love us to apply
that kind of critique to poverty abolitionism.
You know, many of us know not to eat chocolate
from certain brands because of these things,
or we are aware of the climate consequences
of certain purchases or flights or certain
meals.
But, you know, we know that our our cucumbers,
it's local, organic.
We don't know how much the farm hand picked
it.
We know where to get our coffee if we want
to signal certain political values.
But we don't ask how much the workers are
getting paid in there.
I was in London a few weeks ago and I saw
these stickers on stores and they said, you
know, we plight, we pay a living wage.
And I went into a store and I said, Well,
tell me about the sticker.
And they're like, well, you know, the standard
is here, but, you know, our companies decided
to bring it up to here.
I would love to see that kind of thing happening
in America, that consumer push and process.
And so there's groups like Union Plus that
say, hey, you know, you want a candy bar,
you want a beer, These are these are union
made.
These are then there's organizations like
B Corps that says, you know, these companies
have really high standards of environmental
and social consciousness.
They pay their workers well.
And so I think that like shopping and investing
a little bit in solidarity of the poor makes
a lot of sense.
As you as the cell phone example relates.
Right.
A lot of us kind of feel, you know, embroiled
in these kind of morally compromising networks
and we want out of it, you know, and this
is where kind of an argument for poverty.
Abolitionism isn't just an argument for the
end of this depravity and scarcity.
It's about a freer country, a safer country,
a happier country, and a country where you
don't worry so much about our kids.
Speaker 1: You know, I was I was in London
a couple of weeks ago as well, and saw the
exact same stickers and found them interesting.
Should we be economic nationalists in this
conversation in the sense of prioritizing,
For example, like with coffee, there's very
little coffee grown in the U.S., I think maybe
some in Hawaii, and that's basically it.
So it's coming from other parts of the world
in having this conversation.
Should we be economic nationalists in the
sense of focusing on the metrics that relate
to the workers in the U.S.? Or should we be
considering the farm in Costa Rica or wherever?
And then with coffee, there's a middle person
that's often involved where sometimes a lot
of that money actually gets sucked in.
To what degree should we focus on within the
U.S. versus outside of it?
Speaker 6: I think there is and there is something
to be said by starting here.
And the reason is building a political will
to abolish poverty in America.
And I mean that for real.
You know, I think we can and should end poverty
in this land of abundance.
Getting to that goal, I think, motivates further
investments in countries that have far more
poverty in the United States and and could
could could get us there.
But if we can't do it here right in our own
backyard, I don't think we have a chance of
doing it abroad.
So I don't think we have to choose.
And I think that often we have these kind
of scarcity arguments, right, where we're
kind of setting up this false scarcity narrative.
I don't think we have to.
But I think just pragmatically, there is something
to be said about, okay, let's tackle poverty
right here, right now.
Then let's broaden broaden the aperture.
Speaker 1: Last thing I wanted to ask you
about, particularly in the context of the
COVID stimulus bill, is the earned income
tax credit has been a topic of discussion.
I think, generally speaking, it's a good program.
I like the higher numbers.
I think it makes sense in a lot of ways, but
it also has limitations which which you've
talked about.
Certainly it doesn't seem to address the root
causes of poverty and the reasons people might
qualify for an earned earned income tax credit,
child tax credit to begin with.
Can you talk a little bit about that treating
symptom versus disease maybe.
Speaker 6: Right.
So the earned income tax credit is kind of
a wage subsidy that our poorest paid workers,
many of them parents, get every year.
It's a big part of the safety net.
It's about $61 billion a year.
And for a lot of families, man, it's a life
saver.
You know, it is a life saver.
It lifts millions of families out of poverty,
but it doesn't address that problem, that
low wage problem.
Do I think that yes, it is a good idea?
Do we need it?
Absolutely.
Do I think that we need other things that
really cut at the root of poverty?
Yes.
So those would be things like worker power,
expanding representation on corporate boards,
for example, for workers.
Yes.
Finding out ways of making organizing easy
instead of this incredibly hard, slow process
that it is now things to really kind of build
up wages and fight worker exploitation.
And, you know, as we're doing that, let's
definitely make sure those families have enough
to get by with things like the EITC.
So short term solutions and long term solutions.
Speaker 1: Do you see that Democrats or Republicans
are definitively better on this issue, or
is that a lot of political framing and posturing
when there may not be as much daylight as
some would believe?
Speaker 6: No, I think Democrats are definitely
better on this issue.
They're I think on the ground level, there's
a lot of Americans that want this, right.
Most Americans want a higher minimum wage.
Most Americans think the rich aren't paying
their fair share taxes.
Yes, most Democrats and most Republican voters
think poverty now is a result of unfair circumstances,
not a moral failing.
So I think there's a lot of us on the ground
level, neighbor to neighbor to neighbor that
actually agree on these basic issues, economic
justice.
But our electeds are polarized from us, and
that's a problem that we need to fix.
Speaker 1: The book is Poverty by America.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Professor Matt Desmond, sociology department
at Princeton University.
Really appreciate your time and insights.
Speaker 6: Thank you, David.
Appreciate you.